whew visible traces are left of an
election that looks set to change the
country but everyone here is talking
about the results and here at Valley
Asura square in the center of the
capital Tehran there are mixed feelings
you Beast anybody kid our biggest hope
is that we can now get involved in that
our problems will start being solved if
they want to represent us then they have
to listen to us and we should have the
freedom to state our opinions mom I am
we support the supreme leader and all
other countries especially the USA need
to know that we follow only his commands
nobody here believes that the Reformers
apparent success at the polls will lead
to more personal freedom for Iranians
any time soon for example where women's
dress codes or internet censorship are
concerned also tabaci as my I don't have
in Iran we have many conservative social
classes added to that clergy and
religious scholars who are very powerful
they're against removing Islamic dress
codes one member of parliament or one
president alone can't do anything
against that power however with the new
Parliament changes in the political
arena towards more democracy are
conceivable indeed and that's the very
least that the many voters who put their
faith and reformers expect